you mentioned the combine bruce arians
had some thoughts on the reality there
will be no combine here's what he had to
say
for me it's always been
what's on tape
now let's do the background on the
person you know
uh
you go to the combine you fall in love
with those guys in shorts they run four
three then you look at the film though
they don't run four three you know when
i was playing and that guy that ran four
six he's the fastest guy on the field
so the tape don't lie
and you can fall in love and get your
heart broken at the combine
i'm sure there are plenty of coaches and
scouts who
will miss going to indianapolis simply
because
of the
broader experience and the late nights
and
all the drinking that we know goes on
with the coaches and the scouts when
they aren't at the uh lucas oil stadium
watching the workouts but you know i
guess aaron just said i don't need i
don't need an excuse to go somewhere and
drink i'm just gonna drink wherever i am
so for him it's no different not going
to the combine so what fill my glass i
don't care wherever i am it's the
combine but uh you know he makes another
good point the film is what matters and
we get so caught up in all this other
information i feel like the pre-draft
workup is so much more about cya than it
is about
finding some player that we're not
thinking about it's like let's come up
with all the reasons not to draft a guy
and uh and then we won't draft the guy
because we have all the reasons not to
draft a guy it's it's overkill so i
think the nfl will be fine without it
i won't personally miss going after
going every year since 2012 or 2013 i
won't miss it for a year maybe next year
i will and i'll be ready to go back but
uh i i it'll be an interesting case
study in how much of all this other
stuff that has grown up around the nfl
is really critical to the success of the
league miles
well i i would say that i've seen people
fall in love and get their heart broken
at the combine and it has absolutely
nothing to do with the players working
out so that's part of everything i think
that goes on but i i would also say that
i i think when you can have all of the
teams in one place that's when a lot of
deals start getting done and it comes
with agents as well i mean we have the
legal tampering period that starts right
before free agency but then there's also
the illegal tampering that happens at
the combine because everybody is
together and so i mean there are deals
that get made at st almost probably you
know or what is it uh i don't know a
hyde park whatever the heck that
steakhouse is that everybody then goes
to later on at night so yeah prime
whatever it is uh 47 i think so it's
just there's a lot of different reasons
why people like going to the combine i
do like going to the combine it's nice
to see a bunch of friends that you have
from around the league but at the same
time i think you're right it's probably
not as necessary as we make it out to be
but it's still one of those events that
just is on the nfl calendar and you know
it just it makes sense that at the end
of february everybody just descends on
indianapolis
and and the tampering isn't nearly as
random or coincidental as i bumped into
someone at insert name of steakhouse
what happens is
the the agents have they have an
itinerary they've got a schedule
i'm going to see the the cults in their
hotel suite where they otherwise
question and interrogate the incoming
rookies and then i'm going to go see the
cowboys and then i'm going to go see the
buccaneers and you know and and it's
it's all out in the open i i it's a
given i've got seven free agents that i
represent and i'm going to talk to 25 of
the teams about my seven free agents no
one makes any bones about it it's all
untraceable because it all happens face
to face
and everyone does it i i had a team
president tell me years ago that his
team was the last team
that was not tampering pre-free agency
and finally realized
we're the only ones who aren't doing it
we're at a disadvantage we have to start
doing it because
31 other teams are so they'll still find
a way to do it they'll find a way to do
it maybe they're going to need some
burner phones that like on uh breaking
bad and better call saul they'll rip in
half and throw in a garbage can but
they're gonna need a way to do it
they'll find a way to do it and it will
happen it just won't happen as
organically and naturally as it does in
indianapolis
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports